It's all well and good we've got the door opening and closing
But what happens if we wanted to actually use the door handle to open the door?
What if we wanted to walk over to the door and we didn't want it to automatically open but we wanted to say, okay
I want to open this door maybe by pressing the E and to right
So let's think about how we might do that
So in Unreal Engine we can go to edit and we've got project settings here and these project settings are anything
That's relevant to your current project. So we're just going to go ahead and click that and
I'm going to scroll down. There's a whole host of things that we can do here, but let's scroll down to input
So input is underneath the engine heading
under input and let's look at
Action mapping. So let's let's expand this list here
You'll see a list of pre-built things and this is where Unreal Engine have added certain
Inputs to the game that allows you to run around and jump and shoot and
So what we want to do here is we want to add an interaction key
So we're going to go to action mappings and we're going to click the plus button
So we've got a new action map in here. Let's call this interact
Let's also select a key for this
I'm just going to press E on my keyboard and scroll down and I'm going to find the E input here
So whichever button you'd like to do again bear in mind that the buttons not already used
I'm going to click select either and
That's that that's all we really need to do that so we can shut the project settings now
And go to blueprint door. I'm just going to make sure I compile and save again just to make sure everything's there
I'm going to right click and I'm going to type interact now
Now what we can see is we've got action events called interact
Now if we had called that interact something different like if we had called that zebra you would right-click and search zebra and that
Directly correlates to what input we clicked. So whenever we press the E key now
Interact will file
Now there's going to be inherent issue with this
We want to make sure that it's only when we're near the door that we press E
That it works. So let's just disconnect
The reverse key. So we're just going to hold alt on our keyboard and left mouse click
Alternatively you can right-click
Break all links so you can either right-click on a pin and break all links
I like to hold alt on my keyboard and left-click
let's
Let's move this down here
Let's add some space here and we're going to do our first get so we're going to right-click and get player controller
So get player controller, so we're just right-clicked an empty space get player controller
And we're going to drag off there
And we're going to type enable input. So enable and select
So again, make sure you drag off the return value
we're going to enable input and
I think
Yeah, I think
Let's let's see where we end up here. If you've got the target and the player controller is empty. I'm going to hold
control and left mouse drag and
Drag it down there
So that just allows you by holding ctrl on the keyboard it allows you to move something if for example
You just want to break the link and add it again
That's fine as well or you can right-click break link
I think it should go into player controller
Let's see where we end up that might might end up biting us later on but let's see
So I want to disable input from here and again, I'm going to move it there
So I'm going to go to enable
Disable I'm going to compile and save just make sure we're working and
When we do input, I'm gonna play
play this
So when we talked about debugging before actually, this is a good good thing to implement
So when we're speaking about debugging and seeing the wires
Happening a good way as well is if we drag out of pressed and type print
so we'll select the first one print string and
You'll
See a string here
So I'm just going to type input and what we'll see here if we compile and save when the player presses a button
This should fire on the screen and it should say input on the screen and it allows us to detect if things are
Working without seeing the flow. So let's just go ahead and test this out
Let's see if that player controller did actually do what it should have done
So input you see on the top left of the screen there
I'll just play again for you just to make sure you can see that and
So the doors not opening I press e on the keyboard and just look at the top left of my screen in the actual
Viewpoint you see input fire and therefore that's worked
Okay, that's good that we know that that now works. We've got a print string on the screen
And we're using the input
Now the only other thing we really want to do is the doors not closing so we could drag this down to here
to reverse and
That will then close our door. So let's go to compile
Let's go to save
We'll go back into our map. And again now we're just really adding flavor. We're adding functionality to our door
So we're just pressed we're gonna press e now
got input
The door stayed open when we move away from the door
When we move away from the door, there we go. It closes. So that's really nice functionality
The door doesn't open by default. We press e we open the door
The door closes when we leave it if I escape out. I just want to now clean up this blueprint
I don't really need that print string there. I can just hit delete make sure you
Create play here. And the only thing that I'd really want to do now is to add a little bit more complexity again
This is optional if you're feeling comfortable with where you're at right now
This is more optional, but I really don't like these wires. You can imagine
Spaghetti starting to ensue in our blueprint if if we leave wires just dangling all over the place
So what I'm going to do here is I'm going to introduce a concept of a custom event
So I'm going to alt click that wire again, you could right-click break link or you could alt click
I'm going to right-click here. I'm going to type custom
And custom event. So again, just custom custom event. I just added an e there just to start event. So custom event
I'm gonna say
close
door
So I'm going to create a custom event called closed dot. I'm going to reverse on the closed door
Now I'm going to compile and save I definitely need to compile now, this is a compile behavior
So if you're not compiled definitely do that and I'm just going to drag off here. I'm going to type closed door
Now you'll see the closed door is the exact same
As this so again, if I called that zebra you type zebra here click closed door and
Compile save now
This is going to send a message from here to there just through the use of custom event
If I double-click this closed door, you'll see that it selects that so again double click here and it selects that
So you'll see the flow will go from disable input
It'll send a message from there to there and then it'll close the door and it just in my mind
It keeps things a lot cleaner. Just before we leave. I'm going to select everything
I'm going to press C on my keyboard to come in and I'm going to call this open. Let's say open close
door
functionality and
You know just keeps things nice and organized. I'm even going to give it a little color. I'll give it a pinkish color
I'm going to change my alpha value maybe to 0.2. So it drops down the opacity a little bit. I'm going to click OK
Maybe I want to change my font size to 30 again
If the box isn't selected, I wouldn't be able to change that. I want to click the box
Now I have those options and these things up here are getting in my way a bit
I don't really need them. So I'm just going to delete them and
Now we have basic open closed door functionality. The main thing we want to check now is that this function
Fired into this event. We just want to make sure everything's working. So let's compile. Let's save
Let's run through our door again. Let's make sure we take our weapon this time things may have appeared since we last tested it
Let's walk over to the door. The door is not opening. Let's press E
We're through the door. We can shoot whatever's happening and the door shuts behind us